leveling up and housing secretary
Michael Gove is here in the studio with
us this morning good morning hi good
morning Kate
um
morning's papers Boris Johnson should
shut up and go away what do you think he
should do well again I've given advice
to Boris in the past he hasn't always
necessarily followed my advice so I'll
refrain from offering any advice to him
now except to say two things uh he's
made a decision to stand down uh that's
a an individual decision for him but the
work of government goes on
um and today for example the Prime
Minister will be making a series of
announcements about the future of
technology and how we can make sure that
we Safeguard people's jobs in this
country and Safeguard investment but the
other thing that I would also say is in
assessing boris's career and his
contribution to public life I think it's
appropriate take a balanced View and to
recognize that there were significant
contributions that Boris made and that
we should be grateful for his Public
Service previously basically suggested
that he wasn't fit for office well as I
say many of the things that I've said
and Indie done in the past are there as
matters of public
Boris has made his own decision to stand
but I'm asking you your opinion yeah no
no and mine is that um Boris is someone
who has contributed an enormous amount
to public life and now that he's decided
to step down I think it's appropriate
that we should take uh a balanced and
Fair View of his contribution and in
doing so I think that it's only right
that we all acknowledge that we wouldn't
have had uh the speed of the vaccine
role at the fastest in Europe that we
did without boris's leadership without
him having set up the vaccine task force
without him having a great recruited
Kate Bingham for that role I think it's
also the case every day we look at the
the scenes of the war in Ukraine uh
Boris was the Western leader who was
strongest and clearest and earliest in
his support for Vladimir zielinski and I
think it's again important that we
acknowledge that contribution well do
you feel Vindicated that when you said
he wasn't fit for office well Boris
actually then went on to become Prime
Minister he's secured a significant
election victory for the conservatives
and he resolved the vexed brexit issue
the Log Jam in Parliament so again uh he
has a contribution uh to public life
which uh all of us I think as we assess
can consider as one which has been
significant and all of us can be
grateful for the good that Boris did
while he was in office yeah but it's
spat the dummy on Friday and talked
about kangaroo courts I mean hardly
appropriate behavior from a former prime
minister well Boris will have his own
recollection and I'm not asking him
you're set in front of me I'm asking you
I know and uh the critical thing I think
is uh it's a properly constituted
Committee of the House of Commons with
distinguished and experienced MPS on it
neither of us have yet read the report
so we'll have to wait and see and and
you know pass judgment on it later but
no I wouldn't describe uh the committee
as a kangaroo court not at all
um they are still likely to ask for a
vote for a suspension of Boris Johnson
even though obviously it's you know it
doesn't make any difference now would
you vote for him to be suspended well
I'll have to read the report you know
like like every Member of Parliament
because I think all of us will have the
opportunity to vote according to our
judgment on this matter uh I'll read the
report see what the recommendations are
uh make up my own mind we also know that
the um leader of the House of Commons
has the position has the authority to be
able to prevent access of Boris Johnson
to the Palace of Westminster
um would that be a good idea
um well this is just Mischief is
mischievous oh
if everyone who is mischievous was
barred from the House of Commons then I
I think emotions are I suppose well
quite and I can't uh look into anyone
else's heart and discern what their
motives are
um you know these are matters for the
House of Commons authorities I think
it's important that there's a
distinction between the government and
I'm a government Minister part of the
executive and what the House of Commons
overall decides when it um it
establishes its own rules so it's not
really for me to tell the House of
Commons whether individual X or
individual y should be uh in the House
of Commons or uh using its facilities
what would be the benefit of him being
allowed to continue to use the
facilities given that he's been
disparaging about
um a democratically elected committee
well I think there are two things to say
there the first thing is that it's a
tradition that MPS after they stand down
can still as you know as part of the
administration of the their legacy the
you know the work that remains to be
done after they've stopped being mp uh
that uh the House of Commons facilities
in a limited way can be available to
them that's a sort of General principle
and when you've got a general principle
if you're going to make an exception to
it then you need to know the reasons why
we haven't had the committee report yet
the House of Commons will form that
judgment and again I don't think it
would be right for me at this stage just
as an individual MP in this case to uh
and particularly as a government
minister to seek to determine what the
House of Commons collectively will
decide yeah I mean it's not a very it's
not going to be very flattering though
is it given that he's thrown his Teddy
in the corner and talked about a
kangaroo court
well again I haven't read it and um you
know Boris is clearly under what you
know how could it possibly be fluttering
yeah well I think you know boris's
reaction is really realistic here yeah
quite boris's reaction clearly indicates
that he feels that uh it's unfair and
he's been introduced
um uh I can't prejudge that um as you
know I used to be a journalist and one
of the things about being generous is
that you love to anticipate what the
next event might be to speculate and so
on but I'm no longer a journalist my
responsibility now is to concentrate on
government to respect the difference
between government and the House of
Commons and indeed to spend my
day-to-day not necessarily speculating
about this particular report though I
will read it but concentrating on my job
today you know my principle goal is to
make sure that research and development
money the investment that the government
spends on science is spread across the
country so that it's not just an Oxford
in Cambridge that we have brilliant
science but also in Newcastle and
Manchester as well okay
um you know that he's mischievous at
best Boris Johnson you've worked very
closely with him in the past he says
he's leaving for now
what should we read into that well I
think that Boris is someone who made my
observation likes to keep his options
open and again it would be a foolish
person who could claim that they had
predicted every twist and turn in
boris's political career with absolute
accuracy so I don't know what's in his
mind I watched him in the back
previously of course haven't you well I
I've offered um a judgment at various
critical points yes and um I think so
known as well but people perform their
own judgment about uh what I've said in
the past and uh and Boris his own record
my judgment about boris's record is that
even though uh I've been you know I was
obviously critical of him I nevertheless
think in office and you have to judge
people by their actions in office he was
responsible uh on as I say told me you
told me already
um would you support him coming back
again well it's not a decision for me
it's a decision for him but as I say I
won't anticipate what's going to happen
in the future to come back
um when I've as you've indicated when
Boris advice in the past uh he hasn't
he's always been grateful for it but he
hasn't always taken it so I wouldn't be
so presumptuous as to offer advice on
that how surprised were you that he
didn't realize that MPS could not sit in
the House of Lords well again uh I think
the critical thing about the
appointments is that uh Boris made a a
series of recommendations in the illness
list those recommendations were then
passed on by the prime minister to the
independent House of Lords appointments
committee proper process then the
appointments committee sent the list
back to the prime minister with some
names taken off I don't know the reasons
and because the committee is independent
uh nor should I and then the Prime
Minister passes that list uh on to the
palace for final approval so uh the you
know the the the the details of who
might have been on that list and are no
longer I don't know uh all I do know is
that obviously there were some people
who uh uh might have been elevated to
the House of Lords who haven't been
should Nicholas Thurston be suspended
from as an MSP until we discover more
um well I think it's really again it's
really a matter for the you know the SNP
um
you know Nicholas touch is not someone
with whom I agree on very much but I
worked with her during covid my focus is
making sure that the UK government and
the Scottish government work effectively
together for the people of Scotland back
though well again again continue she was
arrested yesterday yeah and then and we
both know that there's a live police
inquiry
um and two other figures have been
arrested as well no and I think that I
shouldn't say anything about her
position
um uh my job is to concentrate on
working with the current first Minister
whom I'll be seeing later this week in
order to talk to him about how I can
help the Scottish people as I say
separate police inquiry and uh you know
I'm old-fashioned about this uh people
are innocent until proven otherwise oh
yeah okay uh we're out of time but I
wondered if you'd indulge me just uh
with a quick thought always indulgent
okay our story
um today about RAF Food Bank yes
thoughts well um it is concerning um I
have service personnel as constituents
uh I've been concerned in the past about
the quality of the accommodation they
have the government continues to provide
cost of living support to individuals
who need it but if you're working in the
armed forces if you're in the services
then you shouldn't have to have records
to food banks I know that defense
ministers will be concerned about your
reports will want to investigate and
will want to do everything possible to
make sure that our men and women in
uniform are properly looked after it's
always a pleasure thank you for joining
us not so thank you thank you